اذا مشاهدينا اهلا بكم انا ميسون عزام
احييكم والتغطيه مستمره للاوضاع في
السودان فمع استمرار المواجهات رغم الهدنه
المعلنه تتفاقم ازمه النزوح فيما تبادل
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الاتهامات
بمواجهه الرعايه الاجانب رغم الهدوء الحذر
في ثالث ايام العيد الا ان الاشتباكات
تتمركز في مدن سودانيه من ابرزها الخرطوم
واندرمان وبحري
ونبدا مشاهدينا من ابرز التطورات
الميدانيه تتواصل لاشتباكات داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
شهدت بعض احياء بحري وام درمان والخرطوم
تحليقا للطيران الحربي بحسب شهود عيان من
جهه اخرى اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع طيران
الجيش بقصف مواقعها في منطقه كفوري
بالخرطوم بحري فيما تواصل ويتواصل انقطاع
التيار او خدمه المياه في مدينه بحري وعدد
من احياء ولايه الخرطوم ومن المقرر ان
تنتهي مساء هذا اليوم هدنه كان وافق عليها
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بينما تواصلت
حركه النزوح من الخرطوم الى الولايات
السودانيه الاخرى
هذا واظهرت الصور تصاعد اعمده الدخان في
مطار الخرطوم الدولي مع استمرار
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
دعونا نتابع النظر
المزيد
نعم اخر المعلومات المتوفره هي انه هناك
هدوء حذر في مناطق متعدده من المناطق التي
كانت تشهد اشتباكات متعدده هذا الهدوء بدا
منذ ساعتين تقريبا هذا هدوء حذر في مناطق
متعدده من ولايه الخرطوم هناك حركه ليست
طبيعيه بالكامل لكن شبه طبيعيه في بعض
المناطق من ولايه الخرطوم بدل مواطنين في
الخروج وهذه الحركه في اغلبها هي حركه
الوزوح من داخل المناطق التي اشتد فيها
الاشتباك
الى مناطق اكثر امنا او الى مناطق يمكن ان
يشهد فيها المواطن استقرارا نسبيا
حركه النزوح لم تكن على السيارات فقط حتى
سيرا على الاقدام الان بدا مواطنون من
مناطق متعدده خرجوا سيرا على الاقدام
يحملون حقائب في مناطق مختلفه وجدنا عددا
منهم وسالناهم عن
وكان واضح ان هناك خلع وتوتر وكذلك انقطاع
للمياه
وفي مناطق خدمات الكهرباء كذلك والان
خدماتها الاتصالات كذلك شبه متوقفه منهم
من يمتلك عربات وقالوا ان هذه السيارات
ليس بها وقود فخرجوا سيرا يبحثون عن مناطق
اخرى اكثر امنا في هذه اللحظات في هذه
اللحظات وفي لحظه خروجهم كان الوضع مستقر
ليس هناك اي نوع من الطاقه الخاص او حتى
المدافع الثقيله والخفيفه التي كانت تسمع
قبل ثلاث ساعات تقريبا سالم عندما نتحدث
عن عمليات نزوح لازلنا نتحدث عن عمليات
نجوح داخلي هناك خارجي ولكنها لازالت
محصوره ومركزه بالداخل السوداني او لا
نعم عمليات النزوح هي ليست داخليه فحسب في
هناك خارجي لكنه محدود الغالب انه داخلي
ما الى المناطق الاكثر املا في داخل
الولايه نفسها او الى ولاياتكم مجاوره
كذلك نشهد ايضا تساؤلات كثيره الان تضوج
بها مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في الحديث عن
المواقع التي توجد بها سيارات تقل
المواطنين الى مناطق ولايات اخرى او تنتقل
الى ولايه اخرى وهذه الاسئله المتكرره من
المواطنين بحثا عن
نزوحهم الى تلك الولايات حتى يبتعدوا عن
اماكن النزاع والصراع كذلك هذا الامر يعني
يشغل الكثير من المواطنين في الولايات
الخرطوم او في المناطق التي تشهد تجدد
الاشتباكات بين الحين والاخرى بسبب الذعر
والخوف خاصه لدى الاطفال والنساء وكبار
السن وهنا السؤال كان يتعلق ايضا اكثر حول
ان كان هناك حدود مفتوحه لدول الجوار ولكن
ابقى سالم نعود الى هذه النقطه للحديث
اكثر الان عن استمراريه خرق هذه الهدنه مع
هذه الاستمراريه تبادل الطرفان الاتهامات
بشان الاعتداء على البعثات الدبلوماسيه
بينما تستمر عمليه الاجلاء للرعايه
الاجانب الجيش اتهمه قوات الدعم السريع
بارتكاب انتهاكات ضد بعثات الدبلوماسيه
ليله امس الجيش السوداني ذكر في بيان ان
عناصر من الدعم السريع اعتدت على السفير
الماليزي والبعثه القطري المتجهه الى
بورتسودان كما تعرض موكب السفاره الفرنسيه
لاطلاق النار مما ادى الى عودتهم وتعطيل
عمليه الاجلاء في المقابل قالت قوات الدعم
السريع في بيان ان طائرات الجيش هي التي
استهدفت موكب السفاره الفرنسيه وقد شددت
الدعم السريع على التزامها بالهدنه وتسهيل
حركه الرعايه رعايه الاجانب
ولمناطق الاجلاء طبعا
[تصفيق]
هذا واكد قائد قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان محمد حمدان دقلو لمنسق السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
التزام قوته المطلق بالهدنه الانسانيه
المعلنه مضيفا ان قواته مستعده لتقديم ما
يلزم من تسهيلات تساعد المواطنين
والجاليات الاجنبيه على المرور الى اماكن
امنه
وكان المستشار الاول لقائد قوات الدعم
السريع فارس النور في مقابله مع العربيه
اتهم مع ناصر قال انها مندسه بتنفيذ
الاعتداءات على البعثات الدبلوماسيه
هنالك الان
كتيبه كامله متفرغه من الطرف الاخر ترتدي
زي الدعم السريع لكي تدق السينما بين
الدعم السريع والمجتمع الدولي هم انضربوا
الرصاص على السيارات السيارات السفاره
الامريكيه هم اعتدوا على
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
ونفى النور للعربيه رغبه الدعم السريع ان
تكون بديل عن الجيش قال ان قوات الدعم
السريع مستعده للاندماج في الجيش بعد
تطهيره من عصابات سيطرت عليه وفق تعبيره
ان الجيش السوداني الان مختطف وابناء
الشعب السوداني وهنا في نقطه
نحن حتى
يعني نحن ما صالحين نفسنا بديل للجيش
السوداني
منيح الناس دايرين نطهر الجيش السوداني من
العصابه التي سيطرت عليه وبعد ذلك الجيش
السوداني هو الاساس لكي نكون جيش قومي نحن
سوف نندمج في الجيش السوداني لكي نكون جيش
رومي يحمي الدستور
يحمل البلاد من الاعداء الخارجيين
هذا هدفنا نحن لسنا بديلين
اعد لسالم الهاشمي من المراسل العربيه
المتواجده في الخرطوم ودعني سالم اشير الى
العواجل الان وتحديدا تصريحات المتحدث
باسم العمليه السياسيه بالسودان يتحدث
طبعا انه وقف القتال هو الاولويه الان
ويقول انه الفرصه الان سانحه لايقاف الحرب
وللعوده للطريق الصحيح سالم لا اعلم ان
كان لدينا رؤيه اوسع عن طبيعه هذه
التصريحات على ماذا تعتمد طبيعه الفرصه
التي يتحدث عنها
نعم ربما تتحدث هذه القوه المقعره عن
مساله
الهدنه وانها يعني الان تشهد استقرار
النسبيا مقارنه بكل هدنه سابقه وانه هناك
من هدنه الى هدنه يكون هناك تحسن قليل في
بعض
النواحي المتعلقه بحياه المواطن خاصه اذا
بتصحبنا بعض الاصلاحات فيما يتعلق باعداد
المائي فتح بعض الطرقات السماح للمواطنين
بالخروج لانه حتى هذه حركه النزوح كانت
وربما صعبه في الايام الماضيه بحكم تمركز
القوات في انحاء مختلفه ومتفرقه تمنع
المواطنين من الحركه في حد ذاتها حتى سيرا
على اقدامهم ربما يفهم هذا الامر في هذا
السياق في انها يمكن ان يبنى عليها بناء
على بعض المعطيات لكن بالمجمل ما زالت هذه
الف هناك اشتباكات وهذا دليل واضح عليه
هذا اليوم يعني منذ صباح اليوم شهدنا
مجموعه من الاشتباكات تحليق للطيران
بمضادات الطيران كذلك المدافع لكن
يمكن ان يفهم في هذا السياق
ادق من ذلك انه هذا الامر لا يمكن ان يتم
الا اذا توافق الطرفان على وقف اطلاق
النار على الارض بمعنى ان المواطن يشعر
فعلا انه لا يوجد هناك اطلاق نار لا يوجد
تبادل
للطلقات او المدافع ولا يوجد ايضا طيران
يحلق في هذا طبعا مستبعد بحسب الواقع على
الارض وبحسب التصريحات التي خرجت من
الرجلين ان كان على العربيه او حتى بصوره
عامه ولكن اسمح لي ان اسال فيما يتعلق
بتحرك المكون المدني بصوره عامه كان هناك
نداءات بان يخرج الناس ويرفع الرايات
البيضاء لفرض
السلام اذا مصحه تعبير على الارض هل هذا
لازال واقع في ظل الهدنه وان كانت هشه وان
كانت يتم خرقها او لا
هذا يمكن ان يكون في المناطق التي هي
الاقل خطوره يمكن ان يطبق هذا الامر في
الاماكن التي لا تتواجد بها اشتباكات
عنيفه ولا تتواجد بها قوات الحجم الذي
تتواجد به في المناطق التي تشهد
الاشتباكات لانه الى طلب هذا الامر في
المناطق التي تشهد الاشتباكات وتشهد ايضا
القصف وكذلك تشهد
مضادات الطائرات والمدافع وبهذا خطوره على
المواطنين انفسهم هم الان يبحثون عن ما
يضمن لهم حياتهم هؤلاء الموجودين في هذه
المناطق فهذا النداء اذا اطلق هكذا قد
يكون فيه خطوره على جزء من المواطنين لكن
اذا حدد بانه يكون في المناطق الاقل خطوره
فسيكون منطقي فعلا
ويمكن تنفيذه كذلك وهو مقلب يعني ينشره كل
عاقل ان يكون من الحرب ليست خيارا بكل
تاكيد وان الكلام هو مطلب لكل هذه الاطراف
حتى الاطراف المتقاطعه ان تتحدث عن
الحكومه المدنيه وعن انشاء السلام بعد ذلك
فهو مطلب لكل انسان لكن يكون في الحفاظ
على واحد الناس لكل تاكيد في المناطق التي
تبتعد قليلا او هي اقل خطوره زعيم نقول
بعباره ادق لاقل خطوره من المناطق التي
تشهد فيها الاشتباكات لان هذه المناطق
ايضا الخروج فيها خطر للغايه بحكم هذه
الاشتباسات بالقذائف كذلك
المدافع الطائرات هذا الامر في خطوره الى
اطلقها على عموم
عندي سؤال فيما يتعلق بقضيه اجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه تم استهداف بعضها ماذا عن
النازحين العاديين المواطنين هل يتم
استهدافهم ايضا بمعنى اخر انه الق ضيه
عشوائيه يمكن القول في بعض الاماكن وبعض
الحالات او لا موضوع البعثات يختلف كليا
عن عمليه نزوح المواطنين السودانيين
المواطنين الذين نجحوا
وخرجوا من هنا غالبيتهم لم يتحدثوا عن
اعتداءات في داخل المدينه بشكل كبير لكن
هناك بعض الشكاوى من اعتداءات تتم خارج
المدينه الطرق التي يتوجهون بها الى احدى
الولايات وردت الكثير من الانباء
المتضاربه ولا نستطيع ان نجزم بها حقيقه
لكن الا ان تاتي من مصدر رسمي لكنها
متضاربه في كل الاحوال لكنها يمكن ان تكون
موجوده وهي بعض الاعتداءات من النهب وسرقه
كذلك وفي طرق البوميه كل هذا يدفعنا الى
الحديث عن غياب تام للشرطه السودانيه في
في هذه الفتره وهذه التساؤلات التي ظلت
مطروحه عن غياب الشرطه في ظل هذه الظروف
من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
على صعيد الجهود الدوليه والاقليميه لوقف
التصعيد في السودان بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل بعد الجهود المبذوله لوقف
التصعيد العسكري بين الاطراف المتنازعه
وانهاء العنف في السودان اضافه الى توفير
الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين السوديانيين
والمقيمين مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي كشف عن توافق سعودي
اوروبي على العمل الجماعي من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان
وحول عمليات الاجلاء المستمره في السودان
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن بدء
عمليه اجلاء سريعه لمواطنيها لطاقمها
الدبلوماسيه بعد ان دخلت المعارك العنيفه
اسبوعها الثاني لفتت الخارجيه الفرنسيه
الى ان العمليه ستشمل ايضا مواطنين
اوروبيين واخرين يتبعون دول حليفه مؤكده
انها حصلت على ضمانات من طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتامين عمليه الاجلاء
بالنسبه لمصر ومع تصاعد الاضطرابات في
السودان اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه
اصابه احد اعضاء السفاره في الخرطوم بطلق
ناري اكدت ان هذا الحادث يؤكد مره اخرى
على ضروره توخي اقصى درجات الحذر حفاظا
على سلامه المواطنين والدبلوماسيين دعت
الخارجيه المصريه المواطنين المصريين
الموجودين خارج الخرطوم الى التوجه الى
مدينتي حلفا وبورتسودان تمهيدا لاجلائهم
وقالت مصادر العربيه ان مصر ستمنحه تاشيره
دخول للرعايه الاجانب القادمين من السودان
اضافت المصادر ان اليونان وقبرص تنسيقان
مع القاهره لاجلاء رعاياهما من السودان
ايضا
المزيد معنا من القاهره الدكتور عماد جاد
عضو لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
المصري سابقا اهلا بك دكتور بدايه
عمليه الاجلاء هذه كيف تنظر اليها امر
طبيعي من كل دوله لحمايه رعاياها ام انه
القادم اسوا فيما يبدو
يعني عاده عمليه الاجلاء من المناطق
الخاطره تبدا بعد وجود توقعات
بان الموقف يزداد سوءا وتدهورا
حينما تكون هناك امال في انها عمليات
محدوده او ان الامور
تتعرض لعمليات هدنه والهدنه تحترم من
الاطراف المتحاربه هنا يتم الحفاظ على
البعثات الدبلوماسيه لكن حينما تدهور
الامر
يبدا ترحيل
المجموعات غير المهمه من البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
وحينما يكون التوقع اكثر سوءا يبدا
الترحيل الشامل وربما نكون دخلنا في
المرحله الاخيره
دول العالم المختلفه تبحث بدات المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بالامس جهودها عبر
الترحيل البحري من ميناء بورسودان واليوم
شاهدنا تح
من دول عربيه ومن بينها مصر لترحيل
مواطنين ودبلوماسيين وايضا
تلقي طلبات من دول مثلي اليونان وقبرص على
اساس دوله دوله
المتحده ايضا بعد غياب طويل وعوده قصيره
جدا تعود لتغلق السفاره مما ينعكس طبعا
على وضع السودان بصوره عامه ولكن دكتور
عماد عندما نتحدث عن مثل هذه الخطوات
وتوقع الاسوء رغم انها شهدنا اكثر من هدنه
وان كانت قد خرقت هذه الهدن ولكن بالمقابل
هناك من يرى فيها امل في الوصول الى حل او
على الاقل الى تهدئه على الارض طبيعه
السيناريو المتوقعه رغم هذه
الهدنه على الاقل الان والتي رغم الخروقات
قال مراسلنا قبل قليل انه تشهد هدوء نفس
نسبي اذا مصحه تعبير عذرا
يعني نحن يفترض
اننا في هدنه وبالتالي الاشتباكات الجاريه
الان والاعتداءات
والقصف وغيره هو اختراق للهدنه وبالتالي
هذه الهدنه تنتهي مسائل يوم لا نعلم بعد
مسائل يوم كيف سيكون الحال اذا كان الواضع
في ظل هدنه 72 ساعه بمناسبه عيد الفطر
يحدث بها ما يحدث انا اتصور وقد تابعت على
شاشاتكم تصريحات
من المستشار السياسي لقائد الدعم السريع
اتصور ان ما قدمه قد يمثل بدايه خيط
للتواصل الى صيغه ماء من اجل انقاذ الشعب
السوداني وحقن الدماء ووقف النزيف يعني
الرجل يتحدث عن الاستعداد
لوقف اطلاق النار وتسليم
السلطه لحكومه مدنيه انا تصور ان هذه بصرف
النظر من الذي اخطا من ليس هذا وقته ولكن
الهدف الرئيسي هو وقفه اطلاق النار الدعم
السريع يقول على مدار الايام الماضيه لم
يستطع اي من الطرفين ان يحسم الموقف
الضحيه الاولى هو الشعب السوداني والقدرات
السودانيه والبنيه التحتيه والمستشفيات
وغير وبالتالي
مغادره الاجانب والعرب هي امر رساله سلبيه
للغايه لكن اذا تم وقفه اطلاق النار اتصور
انه يمكن البناء عليه
الان برايك دكتور عماد ان هناك يد ثالثه
ربما تكون هي المحرك الان على الارض من من
الطرفين معني باستهداف بعثات دوليه
والوصول بعلاقات سيئه جدا مع الدول ان
كانت الاقليميه او الدوليه
بصي حضرتك يعني
صعب التكهن لكن في مثل هذه الامور عاده ما
يسعى كل طرف اعلاميا لتشويه الطرف الاخر
واظهاره بمظهر الخارج عن الاعراف
والقوانين الدوليه وما الى ذلك نقطه ثانيه
عاده في مثل هذه الامور وقد عشنا ذلك في
مصر في 2011
عاده ما يتم الحديث عن طرف ثالث له مصلحه
في تاجيج الصراع كان يقوم باعتداءات على
الطرفين او باعتداءات على البعثات
الدبلوماسيه يرتدي زي ايام من الجانبين
كما اننا لا ننسى ان هناك حرب تدار في
الاعلام لتشويه الطرف الاخر وابراء الذات
وبالتالي كل ذلك وارد اذا اذا تحدثنا عن
دوله متراميه الاطراف والسلاح منتشر
بكثافه وباتت ملعب لقوه يعني
اقليميه ودوليه
فقد تكون هناك اطراف اقليميه لها مصلحه في
استمرار القتال
وصول السودان الى شفا حرب اهليه ثم تقسيمه
حتى يكون ذلك وقد تكون عناصر من النظام
القديم وقد تكون لعبه اعلاميه لان الحرب
في جزء منها تدار اعلاميا
الدكتور عماد جاد عضو لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في البرلمان المصري سابقا شكرا
جزيلا لك
بالنسبه لموقف واشنطن من الاوضاع في
السودان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اعلنت
اجلاء رعاياها من الخرطوم واعلنت تعليق
نشاط سفارتها قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ان بلاده علقت بصفه مؤقته العمليات في
سفرتها بالخرطوم بسبب تزايد المخاطر
الامنيه واجلت جميع الموظفين الامريكيين
وعائلاتهم بامان
مسؤول بوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه قال لان
الاداره الامريكيه لا تتوقع تغيير الاوضاع
الامنيه في السودان على المدى القصير اشار
الى ان واشنطن على اتصال وثيق بالجيش
السوداني والقاده المدنيين لمحاوله تمديد
وقف اطلاق النار اوضح مسؤول في البنتاجون
ان حوالي 100 جندي شاركوا في اجلاء
الموظفين الامريكيين من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم
وكعاده الحروب المدنيون هم من يدفعون
الثمن نقابه اطباء السودان اعلنت ارتفاع
عدد ضحايا الاشتباكات الى مئتين
واربعه وستين قتيلا من المدنيين
و1543 جريحا اللجنه في بيان لها اوضحت ان
هناك الكثير من الاصابات والوفيات غير
مشموله في هذا الحصر حيث لم تتمكن من
الوصول الى المستشفيات لصعوبه التنقل
والوضع الامني في البلاد
ومع تضارب الارقام بشان اعداد الضحايا منذ
اندلاع المواجهات في الخامسه عشر من ابريل
اليكم لمحه عامه على خارطه الوضع الميداني
بحسب مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه للامم المتحده
فان الاشتباكات العنيفه تمركزت في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وكذلك في بحر اما في
الفاشر بولايه شمال دارفور فقد شهدت
اشتباكات متقطعه بين طرفي الصراع باستخدام
الاسلحه الثقيله وايضا الخفيفه هذا وحذرت
لجنو الاحياء في ود مدني بولايه الجزيره
من اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
على طول الطريق من الخرطوم الى مدني والذي
كان احد الطرق الرئيسيه التي يستخدمها
الفارون من العاصمه نتيجه الاشتباكات
المستمره ونقص السلع الاساسيه نزح بين 10
الى 20,000 شخص من النساء والاطفال الى
تشاد المجاوره وفقا لمفوضيه الامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين ورصد مكتب الانسانيه
بالامم المتحده مقتله 413 شخصا واصابه
3500 اخرين في الاشتباكات حتى الحادي
والعشرين من ابريل الجاري ذكر تقرير
للمكتب ان الخرطوم سجلت اعلى عدد من
القتلى ب 132 ثم ولايه شمال كردفان ب 95
قتيل وشمال دارفور بوحده وستين قتيل ومع
استمرار الاقتتال لا يزال عدد القتلى مرشح
للزياده
تحت الحر وعملنا عمليه كبيره في مستشفى
الدوليه الجريده من المستشفى
الدولي لانه فعلي الاصابات الليله اكبر
المزيد ينضم الينا من الخرطوم اسامه ابو
بكر المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر
السوداني اهلا بك استاذ اسامه اسمح لي ان
ابدا بالارقام التي ذكرناها قبل قليل
الحديث انه الارقام تتضارب ما بين جهه
واخرى الارقام المتوفره لديكم ولماذا هذا
التضارب في طرحها
طبعا ما في مؤسسه او منظمه سواء كانت
دوليه او محليه ممكن تدي ارقام
مئه في الميه لحد ما الخسائر سواء كانت
خسائر الضحايا او حتى مصابين السبب ارتفاع
رقعه الجغرافيه بتاعه المعارك اللي هي
داخل مدينه الخرطوم وفي نفس الوقت صعوبه
الوصول لكل الاماكن لاجراء احصاء دقيق هو
الاحصاء يكون معتمده عليه وتيره النزاع
وتيره سقوط الضحايا على هذا الاقل تحصل
تقديرات من المؤسسات المنظمات الصحه
العالميه او وزاره الصحه او غيره نحن في
الهلال احمد السوداني ما عندنا احصاء دقيق
نبدا نعلن عنه لكن طبعا احصاء ولكن لا شك
انكم كنتم على الارض وبالتالي في اطار
عملكم مشاهداتك والارقام المتوفره لديكم
بتزيد كل يوم نحن طبعا بحكم وجودنا على
الارض يعني زي ما انا افتكرش في وقت برضو
قلت للقناه هنا انه ابكم الهلال الاحمر
المتطوعين اللي هما مدربين في الاسعافات
الاوليه والرعايه الصحيه الاوليه بساندو
الكادر الصحي في المستشفيات المنتشره في
العاصمه في اكثر من 18 مستشفى فالحالات في
تزايد
بتيجي للمستشفيات للمستشفيات الشغالين
فيها ناس الهلال الاحمر يعني نحن في
الهلال الاحمر شغالين في 18 مستشفى وحسب
الاحصائيه الرسميه المعلنين وزاره الصحه
انه في اكثر من 120 مستشفى في مدينه
الخرطوم طبعا في جزء كبير من هذه
المستشفيات خارج من الخدمه كبيره من
المستشفيات بيعاني من الصعوبه وكل
المستشفيات عندها نقص بطبيعه الحال حاد في
كل المعينات
والنوازم الطبيه والاسعافيه
انتم كهلال الاحمر وبالمقابل طبيعه
المعوقات التي تواجهكم
لا في ظل الواقع الوضع الحالي الان
فيما يتعلق بالازمه اللي راهي هنا تمام
نحن نشاطاتنا فيما يتعلق بالازمه هنا
بتقوم على حاجتين اساسيتين اللي هي مساعده
الضحايا
يعني مساعده الكوادر الطبيه في المستشفيات
من خلال الاطقم بتاعتنا مش في الخرطوم بس
يعني الخرطوم عندنا
المستشفى
شغالين فيها وعندنا في الابيض لانه برضو
الضوء ما ملقى على المناطق البعيده من
الخرطوم فيها نزاع مسلح وفيها ماسك كبيره
جدا نحن برضو شغالين في الابيض اللي هي
عاصمه ولايه شمال دارفور بمساعده الاطقم
الطبيه برضه بالاتيام المضافات الاوليه
والاخلاق في المشغلين برضو في ولايه شمال
دارفور اللي هي عاصمه الفاشر وشغالين في
ولايه جنوب دارفور هي عاصمتها نيالا
وشغالين في ولايه وسط هي عاصمتها
وماذا عن المعوقات
المعوقات اللي هي في في نقص المعينات
الموجوده في في صعوبه قد
تكون بعض المناطق يعني المعوقات اللي نحن
بنواجهك هلال احمد السوداني تواجهها كل
المنظمات الانسانيه العامله في السودان
اللي هي ابرز عدم توفر المسارات الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف المتنازعه لهذا السبب الناس بتتجه
انها تقنع الاطراف المتنازعه ومش نحن بس
يعني كل المؤسسات الدوليه وحتى الامم
المتحده والحكومات بتسعى بين طرفيه النزاع
انه تامن اوقات معلومه ايام معلومه لوقف
اطلاق النار وضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه لانه بدون ضمان امن الكادر
الكادر المسؤول عن توصيل المساعدات
الانسانيه حتبقى كارثه كبيره جدا
قبل ما تكمل استاذ اسامه عندما تقول انه
ليس هناك من مسارات امنه
ذلك بسبب الوضع بصوره عامه ان تشعر انه
طواقم الصحيه مستهدفه
لا لا ما في بالمنطق
اذا دائما بتقوم بعمل محايد يعني انا اقول
لك معلومه عموما حتى معلومه دي عالميا وفي
القانون الدولي الانساني وهنا مطبقه في
السودان يعني اليوم مثلا لو
طرف من الاطراف شاف السلاح الطبي اللي هو
عامل العلامه بتاعه الهلال الاحمر او
الصليب الاحمدي العلامات العالميه
المعتمده في المؤسسات الطبيه اللي هي
بموجب القانون الدولي الانساني
يمنع المنع الباك اللي هو ضربها حتى لو في
واحد طلب من الاطراف الجيش السوداني مثلا
شاف السياره
تابعه بعمل سريع بتاعه اسعاف طبي او العكس
الدعم سياره تابعه للجيش بتاعه تسعه
ليه لانه معروف انه السلاح الطبي لا يشترك
في العمليات العدائيه
استهداف اصلا مقصود لكن ممكن بعض المنافق
الطبيه يعني تنضرب او يحصل على هدوم بيكون
هدوم خاطئه او هدوم عشوائي لكن ما في حاجه
منظمه ونتمنى لكم السلامه طبعا بكل
الاحوال من الخرطوم اسامه ابو بكر المسؤول
الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني شكرا
جزيلا لك
ازمه اخرى تشهدها السودان ازمه خبز بدات
تتفاقم حيث رصدت كاميرا العربيه احتشاد
الطوابير امام الافران دعونا نتابع
لم يتوقف الامر عند ذلك حيث تهدد ازمه
المياه حياه السودانيين بعدما شهدت البلاد
انقطاعا تاما للمياه الصالحه للشرب اثر
استهداف المعارك محطات المياه في العاصمه
دعونا نتابع
متى ما يجتمع عليه هؤلاء انه كنز من ماء
بئر بعد طول عناء ازمه انقطاع المياه في
السودان تدفع هؤلاء الى الامر مياه عكره
باتت بفعل الحرب صالحه للشرب فلا خيار اخر
يخاطر مدنيون في سبيل البحث عن الماء تشهد
المنطقه هنا وسط الخرطوم معارك محتدمه لم
يترك الرصاص شيئا الا وعليه اثره
رجع رجع جنب البير وقع جنبك
يعود بعضهم محملين بما لا يروي ولا يغني
من
عطاء اما على الضفه هنا نهر على سعته
يلجاون اليه يحتفظون بماء النهر حيله قد
تعينهم لايام بعد معارك سببت نقصا في
المياه الصالحه للشرب
بعد الاحداث الحسنه دي انقطعت تماما
المويه من سبعه صباحا بنكون في الشوارع ما
بنلقى يرد المويه لحد اذان الظهر شحوا
المياه يضرب العاصمه الخرطومه بعد معارك
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع استهدفت
محطات المياه
محطات يصعب الوصول لها واصلاحها لاستمرار
الصراع في محيطها
فيما طالبت منظمه الصحه بوقف فوري لاطلاق
النار خوفا من تداعيات انسانيه قد تكون
الاسوء في تاريخ السودان غذاء السالم
العربيه
يعني شبه كل يعني
ثمانيه ايام بالليل بدايه الاحداث لم يعني
لا تجد اننا ماء تماما ولا يوجد عندنا
كهرباء
هذا هو نشرت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه صورا
لما قالت انها عمليه اجلاء مدنيين من
الخرطوم باتجاه فورد سودان ولم تحدد
الوكاله اذا كانت العمليه تخص نقل
دبلوماسيين اجانب ام رعايه دول اجنبيه
مقيمين بالخرطوم دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على كل المتابعه عمليه النزوح من السودان
الى تشاد ولا جو هناك والتي تقدرها الامم
المتحده بحوالي 20 الف سوداني ينضم الينا
من العاصمه التشاديه الجميله علي فاضل
الاعلامي اهلا بك سيد علي بدايه عندما
نتحدث عن 20 الف لاجئ حتى الان سوداني
لجاوا الى تشاد نحن نتحدث عن فتح الحدود
ام نوع ان هناك حالات خاصه معينه
اهلا وسهلا بكم طبعا الاوضاع في السودان
واستقبال جاد للاجئين لم تبدا اليوم او لم
تكون وليده اليوم ان منذ الحرب في دارفور
عام 2003 حتى هذه اللحظه استقبلت دوله
تشاد الالاف بل مئات الالاف من اللاجئين
في اراضيها واودتم خلال عشرين عاما وهذه
الازمه التي اندلعت الان تزيد الطين بله
كما يقولون الان كانت تستقبل عادات كبيره
جدا من اللاجئين كما قال الصليب الصليب
الاحمر انا سمعته اليوم الصليب الاحمر قال
انه مستعد لاستقبال 100 الف لاجئ في
الحدود التاليه على الحدود التجاريه
السودانيه
انتم تعرفين الكثير من الناس يعرفون تمام
ان شادو والسودان تربطها علاقات واشتراك
او كما يقولون ترابط بين القبائل
وايضا بين القبائل وسنتحدث بعمق حول هذه
الن قطه ولكن ابقى معي اسمح لي ينضم الي
الان من الخرطوم عبر الهاتف فارس النور
مستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
اهلا بك سيدي بدايه تقييمك الاولي لهذه
الهدنه وهل نتوقع ان يتم تمديدها او لا
يا سيدتي هذه القدة يعني نحن وافقنا عليها
ونحن في كل الهدن السابقه نحن من نقترح
الهدنه ونحن من وافق عليها غرضنا وهدفنا
الاساسي في ذلك ان نخفف على بني شعبنا وان
نخفف على
الدعسات الدبلوماسيه التي تريد ان تغادر
البلاد
وهذا دورنا الذي نقوم به في كل وقت وحين
واذا من قرارات موجوده فهي من الطرف الاخر
ومن طرف ثالث يريد ان يعني يدق الصين
بيننا وبين المجتمع الدولي
اذا سيد فارس اسمح لي ان ابدا بالنقطه
الاولى هل يعني انكم تعلنون الان عن مطلب
جديد لتمديد الهدنه مجددا او لا
نحن مستعدون
اذا كان هنالك حوجه انسانيه او حاجه لا
رعايه اجانب نحن مستعدون لتمديد هذه
الهدنه
الانسانيه
وليس لدينا اي مشكله في ذلك هل هناك من
حوجه انسانيه برايك او لا لانه من حسب
بحسب ما نتابع الوضع الانساني ماساوي هناك
عمليه نزوح كبيره جدا وبالتالي هل هناك من
حاجه بالفعل لتمديد الهدنه
الان هنالك محطات المياه ضربت ونحن نحتاج
الى النصل موصل المهندسين الى اماكنها لكي
يستطيعوا ان يصلحوها لا نستطيع الان في
بعض المناطق لانها يعني خطيره عليه على
المهندسين نحتاج لهذه الهدنه ونحن ليس
لدينا مانع في كل ما يخفف على الشعب
السوداني في ذلك طيب ذكرت انه انتم معنيين
بهذه الهدنه ولكن هناك طرف ثالث يعمل على
افشالها بمعنى اخر هناك توافق يمكن القول
على الاقل الان وعلى مستوى الهدنه ما
بينكم وما بين الجيش السوداني
انا اتحدث بالكتابه
في ذلك لان
الجيش السوداني الان لا يملك قراره يعني
قراره مختطف من فئه قليله وتصريحات الغابه
مضطربه
ولذلك لا استطيع ان اتكلم عنهم وانا اتوقع
ان هنالك فئه
متحكمه هي من ادخلت الجيش
جيش السوداني هو جيش البلع البلاد ونحن
مقتنعون انه هنالك شرفاء في هذا الجيش
مختلف انه سيعودون الى جاده الصواب ولكن
هناك فيها متحكمه هذه الفئه لها عصابات
ترتدي زي الدعم السريع ترتدي احيانا زي
الحركات تضرب الباحثات الدبلوماسيه تضرب
يعني بالمنطقه يا اختي الكريمه بالمنطق
المتكلم
اسمح لي سيد فارس هل انت تقول بانه بالفعل
ربما يكون هناك من كان يرتدي زي الدعم
السريع وهو استهدف البعتات الدوليه
هذا ما تقوله
من الاعداء طيب سؤال الاخير فيما يتعلق
بالبعثات البعثه الفرنسيه وعمليه التنسيق
مع هذه البعثات وعندما تخرج هذه البعثات
المراقبون يرون في ذلك بانها
توقعات للاسوء ماذا تتوقعون
نحن
الان نمر بظروف صعبه جدا ولكننا نجتهد في
اجلاء هؤلاء الدبلوماسيين ولكن هنالك زي
ما قلت لك هنالك الان بيان طلع بان دعم
سريع استهدف ما اعرف الاحساسات
الدبلوماتيه في نقطه انا اقول اذا كان
المتكلم مجنون فالمستمع عاقل ما الذي يجعل
الدعم السريع وهو الان يعني يحشي للدعم
الدولي لقضيته للعمليه السياسيه للتحول
الديمقراطي ما الذي يجعله يعني اي هدف نحن
نكسبه او نجنيه من استهداف هذه
الاحساء البعض يرى انه بقاء مثل هذه
الباحثات سيد فارس في مصلحه
كي تحمي نفسها ولا تتوسع عمليه الاقتتال
نحن لا نحتاج الى
رهائننا سلامه المواطنين السودانيين في
الاول ويهمه سلامه البحصات الدبلوماسيه
ولا اعتقد ان اننا في حوجه الى رهائن لكي
نواصل معركتنا واضحه هي من اجل حقوق
الانسان هي من اجل التحول الديمقراطي لذلك
هي معركه نحن نديرها بشرف هنالك طرف اخر
هو يريد ان يدق ليفين يريد ان يعود الينا
الى الانقلاب اريد ان يعيد يعيدنا الى
الشموليه هذا هو الذي
اعلى الى الى هذا الشيء من الخرطوم فارس
النور مستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو شكرا جزيلا لك
وهذه عوده مشاهدينا الى ما كنا نتحدث عنه
عن عمليه اللجوء وموجه لجوء كبيره من قبل
السودانيين الى تشاد كنا نتحدث مع السيد
علي فاضل اعلامي من هناك اهلا بك مجددا
سيد علي كنت تتحدث عن العلاقه الوثيقه ان
كانت الجغرافيه او فيما يتعلق بالقبائل
السودانيه التشاديه سؤالي مركز حول فتح
الحدود لللجوء بصوره عامه من قبل تشاد وان
كان تاريخ اللجوء في تشاد ليس بالجديد
ولكن ماذا عن وضع الحدود الان
هي كانت لم تغلق حدودها ابدا
على الاخوه السودانيين منذ منذ تاريخ
الحروب التي بدات بين
السودانيين سواء في داخل السودان او في
داخل كاد الان تشاد ارسلت جيوش ارسلت
عساكر الى المناطق الحدوديه لتامينها
تحسبا من اندلاع اي عمليات تخريب في
المنطقه الحدوديه يعني قبل اسبوع كاد
ارسلت جنود لتامين المنطقه الحدوديه بين
جاد والسودان لان هذه المنطقه منطقه
مفتوحه ليست هناك نهرا ولا هناك بحرا يربط
بين السودان وجاد وانما هي منطقه
صحراويه مفتوحه انه ممكن يتسلل المجرمون
خلال هذه
الفتره المضطربه الى داخل الاراضي الكاديه
وممكن يقومون بعمليه لذلك كان ارسلت جيشنا
الان لتامين المنطقه الحدوديه الحاجه
الثانيه ان السودانيين الذين لجاوا من
الاراضي السودانيه خوفا من الحروب الان
المندلعه ودخلوا الاراده التجاديه سيجدون
منطقه امنه لوائهم واستقبالهم كما استقبلت
قبل عشرين امن اخوته من دارفور
التحضيرات لهذه الاعداد الكبيره وماذا عن
العشرين الف اين يتواجدون الان
الشراب تقوموا بتقديم الاكل والشراب على
حسب امكانياتها ولكن هناك في منظمات دوليه
كمنظمه الصليب الاحمر الدوليه التي هي
اسلم متواجده في هذه المنطقه منذ عشرين
عاما فهي بمساعده السلطات التجاديه ستقوم
هؤلاء اللاجئين وتقدم لهم الماوى والاكل
والشراب كما قدمت لي اسالك السودانيين
قبلهم الذين لجاوا الى الاراضي التعاديه
الحاجه الثانيه تشاد اراضيها مفتوحه
لاستقبال الاخوه الاخوه الاخوه السودانيين
وكما بدات حديثي ان هناك في قبائل مشتركه
بين كادو والسودان يتجاوز عددها 30 قبيله
بين كادو والسودان فجاد لا تستطيع ان تغلق
ابوابها امام الشعب السوداني والذي يعتبر
جزءا من الشعب التشادي ايضا كما ان
السودان لم تغلق يوما حدودها على وجه
الشعب التشادي فانا اقول
الان ما يجري الاراضي السودانيه ستتاثر
بايجاد من الناحيه الامنيه من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه من الناحيه الاجتماعيه من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
ان هناك في بضائع كثيره تصل الى تشاد عن
طريق
الاراضي السودانيه كالسكر والارز
والمكرونه فهذه الان تتوقف هذا يتاثر به
السكان المناطق الحدوديه من الشعب التالي
وكذلك من الناحيه الامنيه ايضا ان اللجوء
الاف السودانيين الى الاراضي الكاديه اكيد
محتاج الى تعزيزات امنيه لكي نستطيع عمليه
تنظيم طبعا كامله على كل نتابع التطورات
والعين على الحدود التشاديه السودانيه
الاعلامي علي فاضل من العاصمه التشاديه
شكرا جزيلا لك
عمليه اجلاء اخرى قامت بها السعوديه حيث
قالت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان مواطني
المملكه الذين تم اجلائهم من السودان
وصلوا الى البلاد اضافه طبعا الى عدد من
رعايه الدول الاخرى بينت الوزاره في بيان
ان القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه اجلت
واحدا وتسعين سعوديا وحوالي 66 شخصا من
عشر الدول الاخرى عربيه واجنبيه الخارجيه
اكدت ان المملكه عملت على توفير كامل
للاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه الاجانب
تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
هذا ومن جانبه قال النائب وزير الخارجيه
السعودي ان معظم السعوديين الذين طلبوا
الاجلاء من السودان تم اجلائهم وخلال
استقباله السعوديين والرعايه الاجانب
القادمين من السودان الى جده اوضح نائب
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه ان هناك تكاتفا
بين كافه الاجهزه لتنفيذ عمليه الاجلاء
مؤكدا ان وزاره الدفاع السعوديه لعبت دورا
كبيرا في تنفيذها واضاف ان لدى وزاره
الخارجيه توجيهات للعمل على راحه
السعوديين في الخارج
المزيد ينضم الينا من جوبا نائب رئيس جبهه
كفاح السودانيه حذيفه محي الدين البلول
اهلا بك سيدي بدايه قراءتك للمشهد وماذا
تتوقعون الان من تطورات
طيب التحيه لكم وافتكر انه نحن في الاسبوع
الثاني للاشتباكات
هذه العمليه الاجلال الرعايه
الدول المختلفه
يحتضر انه هذه
من شانها ان تفاقم الاوضاع في السودان
وهذه دلاله واضحه لفشل المجتمع الدولي
للضغط على الطرفين الطرفين النزاع في وقت
الشامل لهذا لوقفه اطلاق النار
ولكن الا تعتقد انه الحل يجب ان يكون
سوداني داخلي
نعم سوداني داخلي
الان الامم المتحده كبيره جدا في السودان
وهي
اتت عبر في في يونيو 2020 والمهمه
الاساسيه بتاعتها مساعده السودانيين في
الانتقال الديمقراطي
وحمايه السلام وكذلك
اللعب بدور كبير جدا في في في تحيات
الاوضاع للانتخابات حره ونزيهه انا افتكر
انه هذه العمليات الاجلاس توضح بصوره
واضحه انه المجتمع الدولي فشل فشلا ذريعا
في الضغط على الطرفين في وقف اطلاق النار
ينبه
لمستقبل النزاع واستمراره ومما يؤدي الى
اتساع رقعه النزاع المسلح وفي اكثر من
خيار واكثر من سيناريو يطرح البعض يتخوف
من ان يتم تقسيم السودان كنا نتحدث عن
الجنوب السوداني والسودان والان ربما يتم
تقسيمه بشكل اكبر ولكن اسمح لي كونك تتحدث
عن صراع الرجلين وانه كان الهدف الاساسي
التحول المدني المكون المدني ايضا لم يكن
عامل فاعل وضاغط على الارض ومتوحد اليس
كذلك الا يتحمل المسؤوليه
طبعا انا افتقد عنه لما اتحدث عن اسباب
النزاع ولكن اسباب النزاع انا بفتكر انه
هي دي صوره مباشره هو الاتفاق الايطالي
الاتفاق الايطالي اللي هو عزز الانقسام
داخل المكونات المدنيه وعزز الانقسام داخل
المكون العسكري وافتكر انه المبعوث
الامم المتحده
لعب في في توتر هذه الاوضاع ولعب دور كبير
جدا في في توسيع الشقه والازمه بين المكون
العسكري بانحيازه قليله جدا من
الاحزاب خفيفه الوزن السياسي والسند
الجماهيري
وعملت على على استقطاب كبير جدا بين هذه
المكونات انا افتكر انه الحرب بهذه السبب
اساسي مباشر فيها هذا الاتفاق الايطالي
الذي عزز الانتقام في المشهد السياسي
السوداني وعزز الانقسام داخل المكون
العسكري
رئيس جبهه كفاح السودانيه حذيفه محي الدين
البلول شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
طبعا رعايه دول اصابهم الخوف من الممارسات
مجموعات الدعم السريعه داخل سكنيه وهي
تفتش المنازل وتصادر الاموال وتعتدي على
الامتصاد الدبلوماسيه دون اي مراعه لحرمه
هذه البعثات ولقونيه حتى دون اي مراعاه
لحرمه المواطنين
هذه المجموعات منتشره داخل احياء السكنيه
داخل المجمعات الخدميه وتقوم
بافعاله الخوف
الحياه
في المقابل كشف محمد حمدان دقله قائد قوات
الدعم السريع في تصريحات ايضا للعربيه كشف
انه متواجد في الخرطوم برفقه مقاتليه حيث
يحرص على توجيههم في المعارك وايضا تتبع
تطورات الاشتباكات متابعه
شبابنا
وبعد ساعات من تصريحات حمضتي نشرت على
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي فيديو يظهر قائد
الدعم السريع وهو يرتدي زييا عسكريا ويحمل
سلاحا وهو يعد الظهور الاول له منذ بدء
الاشتباكات في السودان
مشاهدينا الان الى ابرز الاخبار الدوليه
الاخرى في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه ابدى
الرئيس الاوكراني عدم احترامه لاتفاقيه
مسك مضيفا ان الهدف منها لم يكن لانهاء
الحرب نتابعه ارجوك حكومتنا لم توقع على
اتفاقيات منسك انا لم اوقعها كرئيس لقد
وقعوها قبلي انها الحقيقه في رايي
اتفاقيات منسك ليست عمليه لانهاء الحرب
الجميع بحاجه الى فهم هذا لقد كانت عمليه
تحديد المكان الذي توقفت فيه روسيا احتلت
شبه جزيره القرم وضمتها دون قتال للاسف لم
تقاتل اوكرانيا من اجل القرم بعد ذلك
استولت على جزء من دومباس بدات الحرب وبدا
الموت وفي تلك اللحظه تعرفون وقعت
المجموعه الرباعيه المكونه من فرنسا
والمانيا وروسيا واوكرانيا اتفاقيات لوضع
خطه الاجراءات لانهاء الحرب هذه الحرب على
الرغم من انه يطلق عليها احد في ذلك الوقت
حربا
اكد في المقابله الخاصه مع العربيه اكد ان
انضمام بلاده الى حلف الناتو يحتاج الى
موافقه جميع اعضائه المتابع
ني اوكرانيا ليست عضوا في النيتو وتحتاج
ان يوافق جميع الحلفاء لتصبح اوكرانيا
جزءا من النيتو انتبهوا لما يمثله حلف
الناتو بالنسبه لروسيا اعتقد ان هذا مجرد
عذر خلال هذه الحرب اصبحت فنلندا عضوا في
النيتو وقالت روسيا ان النيتو لن يكون
ابدا على الحدود مع روسيا لا ارى ان دول
النيتو تشن الان اي نوع من الحرب لا ارى
وجودا للناتو داخل الحدود الروسيه لا ارى
اي جندي من النت يقتل الروس اما عندنا اتى
الجندي الروسي وفعل كل هذا على اراضينا
قال مسؤولون محليون ان ما لا يقل عن خمسه
صواريخ روسيه اصابت مدينه خاركيف في شرق
اوكرانيا والمناطق المحيطه بها حيث كتب
حاكم المنطقه على تطبيق تيليجرام ان
صاروخا اصاب منزلا في احدى القرى جنوب
المدينه بينما تسبب صاروخ اخر في اندلاع
حريق كبير في المدينه نفسها والحق بعض
الاضرار في مباني المدنيه هذا وتطلق روسيا
منذ اشهر طائرات مسيره وصواريخ ضد مجموعه
متنوعه من الاهداف الاوكرانيه في محاوله
لتدبير البنى التحتيه الحيويه بحسب
التصريحات الرسميه الاوكرانيه اعلنت وزيره
الداخليه الالمانيه توصل الحكومه
والنقابات العماليه الى اتفاق بشان رواتب
اكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون موظف في
القطاع العام اوضحت الوزيره في بيان ان كل
عام سيتلقى ما مجموعه 3000 يورو على شكل
اقساط حتى فبراير العام المقبل للمساعده
في التعويض عن التضخم
احتج نائب وزير الخارجيه الصينيه سونوي
دونج على تصريحات رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
بشان تايوان حيث ذكر نائب وزير الخارجيه
الصيني لسفير كوريا الجنوبيه ان تصريحات
الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي غير مقبوله على
الاطلاق مضيفا ان الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي
لم يشر الى مبدا صين واحده لكنه ساوى بين
قضيه تايوان وقضيه شبه الجزيره الكوريه في
اشاره منه الى قضيه شبه الجزيره الكوريه
وقضيه تايوان التي تختلفان تماما في
طبيعتهما
دعا مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل في مقال القوات
البحريه للدول الاعضاء في التكتل الى
القيام بدوريات في مضيق تايوان وشدد بوريل
على ضروره ان تكون اوروبا حاضره بشده في
قضيه تايوان التي اعتبرها مهمه على الصعيد
الاقتصادي والتجاري والتكنولوجي بوريل دع
القوات البحريه الاوروبيه للقيام بدوريات
في مضيق تايوان للدلاله على حرص اوروبا
على حريه الملاحه في هذه المنطقه
هذه اخبار دوليه ولكن احداث السودان في جل
نشراتنا على راس الساعه نايف الاحمر
مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات